bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui refait la
semaine politique et parlementaire avec
à mes côtés kathia gilder bonjour katia
bonjour oriane et c'est une semaine
chargée sur le front social
manifestation des policiers grève dans
les transports et la mobilisation dans
la rue qui se poursuit contre la loi
travail deux manifestations ont eu lieu
cette semaine
une mobilisation nationale est annoncé à
paris le 14 juin et l'état d'urgence a
donc été prolongée pour deux mois après
les sénateurs les députés ont donné le
feu vert se maintient l'état d'urgence
sera donc en vigueur pendant l'euro de
football qui commence le 10 juin
prochain en france
premier sujet de friction dans la
primaire à droite le vote des français
de l'étranger bureau politique tendue
mardi au siège des républicains un
compromis a finalement été trouvé entre
vote papier et vote électronique
mais la compétition entre les candidats
c'est qu'ils vouent leur vie t2
parlement hebdo cette semaine et david
douillet bonjour vous êtes député les
républicains des yvelines vice-président
la région ile-de-france président de la
fédération l'appui qu'un des yvelines et
vous êtes chargé aux conseillers à la
région ile-de-france de l'action
internationale et du tourisme va en
parler tout à l'heure mais d'abord place
à l'actualité politique
et on commence par lundi il y en a qui y
va arnaud montebourg de retour en
politique c'est la question
pour arnaud montebourg et ses soutiens
l'ascension du mont beuvray avait comme
un air de campagne
et pourtant à l'arrivée pas de
déclaration de candidature mais plutôt
un appel lancé aux français je vous
propose de bâtir dans les mois qui
viennent un grand projet alternatif pour
le pays
ce projet pour la france venez le faire
avec nous et faisons le ensemble il sera
bien temps ensuite s'il a la consistance
que j'espère il sera bien temps de se
décider sur les candidatures
l'ancien ministre en a profité pour
réaffirmer sa vision de la gauche dans
une anna fort comme pour mieux viser
françois hollande
être de gauche être de gauche c'est
considérer que le pouvoir politique doit
être parfois supérieures au pouvoir
économique
être de gauche c'est aimer l'invention
du futur être de gauche c'est aimer et
chérir sa patrie c'est romain gary et le
pape françois et à tous ceux qui voient
cette accélération comme une concurrence
au mouvement d' emmanuel macron arnaud
montebourg fait comme si de rien n'était
mais cherche pas de différence j'ai pas
de similitudes importantes
alors comment trouver un espace
politique entre françois hollande et
jean luc mélenchon en passant par une
primaire de toute la gauche
il serait souhaitable que cette
confrontation d'idées qui est saine qui
est juste et nécessaire elle ait lieu
dans une primaire de toute la gauche
pour nous on va continuer de la demande
et la primaire toute la gauche arnaud
montebourg se donne jusqu'à l'été pour
construire ce projet participatif avant
peut-être une véritable déclaration de
candidature david douillet ce que vous
prenez au sérieux le projet montebourg
si je puis dire ce qui peut être un
candidat sérieux pour vous la droite
d'abord ça va être un candidat sérieux
pour françois hollande par quoi je crois
que là on a on a une petite accumulation
de ce côté on a pas mieux que les autres
pour les primaires de la droite elle en
train de se faire à gauche vivement
entre
je m'accroche une bourre et puis tous
les autres qui arriveront par la suite
le président lui-même qui de par ce
qu'il dit parce qu'il fait je trouve à
titre personnel est déjà en campagne
bon montebourde emmanuel macron c'est
l'illustration de la difficulté de
françois hollande à s'imposer comme
candidat légitime bah déjà la difficulté
du président c'est d'être président
voilà c'est sa grande difficulté depuis
le début de son quinquennat il a été un
bon candidat
il a gagné il a jamais été président
c'est ça la vérité on s'en est rendu
compte à l'assemblée je pense que mes
collègues sénateurs diront peut-être la
même chose mais en tout état de cause
les français l'ont compris et le font
ressentir à travers les les sondages
d'impopularité qu'il qu'il bénéficie
aujourd'hui bon sa politique elle est
clairement un désastre absolu
ce matin encore à la radio j'entendais
des salariés qui explique encore et qui
ont encore 7,7 conséquences quotidiennes
de la suppression des heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
voilà les gens n'ont pas oublié ils le
vivent au quotidien
c'est 200 ou 300 euros important pour
des millions de familles françaises
ils ne les ont plus cette surtaxation
taxation des ménages des entreprises
dans notre pays qui a eu lieu dès 2015
après l'allègement mais c'est un coup de
dupes on taxe beaucoup au début on en
retire un peu à la fin pour avoir une
petite attitude électoralistes voilà les
gens sont pas dupes yann argos qui dit
parler franchement qui met un peu les
pieds dans le plat c'est emmanuel macron
vous vous en pensez quoi
c'est une blague c'est une blague blague
c'est une blague
moi je sais ta vie de jean pierre
chevènement par exemple nous avait dit
chose de très juste je trouve ou lorsque
si on reste ministre on ferme sa gueule
sinon quitte le gouvernement
ballack est là aujourd'hui je ne
comprends pas enfin je pas le seul on
discute souvent et que ce soit à gauche
comme à droite beaucoup de citoyens
comme moi ne comprennent pas comment on
peut créer un jour
un parti qui n'est ni de droite ni de
gauche et en même temps rester dans un
gouvernement de gauche et ne pas être la
correction pour le ministre sur bien des
sujets le dernier en date le les
salaires des patrons des grands patrons
ou des hauts salaires est désavoué en
permanence se désabonner en permanence
les ados dont la cacophonie ce cas vous
ne confère le mental elle est là elle
existe keane qui ne démissionne pas ou
que françois hollande et manuel valls ne
fasse pas preuve de plus d'autorité que
les deux les deux les deux voilà il n'y
a pas de cohérence il n'y a pas de
logique
alors tout le monde va s'y faire les uns
contre les autres en catimini ou
publiquement de temps en temps
montebourg on est l'exemple absolu ben
si les partis du gouvernement
au moins il a eu ce courage philippe
était aussi par exemple bon bateau aussi
voilà donc tout coule déjà depuis
longtemps sans même leur part mais c'est
bien au moins ils ont ils ont ils ont
une colonne vertébrale ce qui n'est pas
le cas de des personnages que vous
m'avez site étant premier ministre le
musée l'économie la cc c'est pas bien et
la cacophonie elle se ressent je dirais
c'est comme c'est comme la lfh image en
montagne ça fond ça coule dans les
vallées voilà aujourd'hui ça coule dans
les rues la cacophonie élites ont bien
compris le message
on va y revenir david douillet on va
passer au mardi journée qui a débuté par
une interview matinale du président de
la république françois hollande invité
de la matinale d'europe 1 le chef de
l'état a redit sa détermination à faire
passer la loi travail mais il a aussi
endossé ses habits de campagne ne se
privant pas d' attaques contre la droite
tous les français quelles que soient
leurs revenus payent des impôts de
consommation et quand je vois que
certains candidats aux primaires de la
droite veulent augmenter la tva je dis
ce n'est pas juste parce que ça va
toucher tous les français indifféremment
il est entré en campagne françois
hollande plus contredit il a expliqué
aussi qu'il aurait pas dû toucher la tva
sociale que sarkozy avait mis en place
voilà donc c'est des contradictions
permanentes bien sûr qu'il en campagne
évidemment qu'il en campagne il est en
campagne depuis bien longtemps et il est
doux et voilà il est doué il est doué ce
qui s'est passé
hier soir on est un exemple caricatural
l'explosion du groupe écologiste à
l'assemblée excusez moi mais je dois
vous chamboulé vaut jouer parce que tout
ça est et est une stratégie qui est très
bien mené qui est finement menée et qui
aboutit à des choses comme celles ci
justement parce qu'il ya quand même une
colère sociale très forte une
contestation politique et finalement y
tient et tiendra sous la halle très
forte attention pas tomber dans le
panneau
non mais en tout cas il est quand même
attaqué de toute part rarement un
président de la république a été attaqué
deux de telle manière vous les
reconnaissez nous allons tenir le choc
mais être tenir le choc de quoi il est
au chaud aziz est ce facile par contre
d'être en totale contradiction avec ce
qu'il n'a jamais dit ou ce qu'il ne dit
pas ou ce qu'il a man who ce qu'il n'a
ce qu'il a menti il a menti à tous ceux
qui lui ont fait confiance quand ils
vont faire la table les dons europe et
non seulement ça va pas mieux mais ça
s'empire
voilà la loi le connerie elle est loin
elle est là si des gens de gauche et
surtout malheureusement et je pas des
casseurs d'extrême gauche viennent fiche
la pagaille dans nos rues et aujourd'hui
ça on n'en parle pas suffisamment dans
les médias mais occasionne par rapport à
des grèves qui sont mises mise en place
à une pénurie d'essence dans tout le
pays sauf en ile-de-france pour ça qu'on
a pas le passé mais dans tout l'ouest du
pays ont tout y est on est en train
depuis avoir d'essence
on aime le pôle il est payé en train de
se bloquer depuis depuis hier c'est bel
et bien parce qu'il a menti à tout le
monde
il a voulu faire plaisir à tout le monde
y a personne et puis voilà et une
politique c'est comme si rouler à 200 km
heure sur l'autoroute avec les yeux
bandés abandonné bas on s'expose
et là il est en train d'exploser et
c'est la france qui ont subi les
conséquences
alors on va passer à l'actualité de
votre parti qui a réuni son bureau
politique
mardi il était question la primaire à
droite est de savoir notamment comment
les français de l'étranger
allez voter pour cette élection ambiance
tendue et compétition au menu comme nous
le raconte quentin calmait
une heure de réunion pour éteindre la
première polémique de cette primaire
finalement le compromis entre le vote
papier et le vote électronique des
français de l'étranger a été adopté à
l'unanimité dans les plus grandes villes
du monde qui concentre le plus de
français on va travailler à
l'installation de bureaux de vote
physique pour ça il faudra bien sûr que
ce soit possible sur un plan de
l'organisation que ce soit légal que les
pays le valide dans le reste des
endroits ça sera votre internet on a
arrêté la date du 15 juillet donc le 15
juillet prochain tous les français qui
vivent à l'étranger sauront où il vote
la fin de deux semaines de débats au
sein du parti
certains accusant nicolas sarkozy
d'avoir voulu restreindre le nombre de
votants à l'élection interne
d'autres faisant valoir l'équité entre
les électeurs au début c'était papier
pour tout le monde on trouve un accord
partagé entre papier scrutin
électronique
tu as ni coup de force ni opérations de
re de frein de qui que ce soit ne pas
changer les règles tout temps c'est pas
la première modification il faut
vraiment que ce soit la dernière
et c'est bien la haute autorité qui a la
main sur l'organisation des primaires
c'est pas le bureau politique
un bureau politique ou le ton serait
monté entre nicolas sarkozy et alain
juppé et la fin d'une première zone de
turbulences sur ce scrutin
encore inédit à droite david douillet
vous étiez à ce bureau politique est ce
que c'est vrai que le ton est monté
donc elle intervient non alors j'ai une
notion du ton qui monte pas c'est pas
normal alors non ça pas du tout monté un
bureau politique ça sert à quoi
justement à se rassembler pour discuter
des choses qui vont qui vont pas se
projeter dans l'avenir
c'est l'avis du parti bon voilà une
primaire elle est organisée
elle est organisée par thierry solère il
le fait bien
ce pas simple il ya des candidats de
poids étant mieux avec de grosses
qualités pour les uns et les autres bien
en train d'y aller ça il ya des zones
d'incertitude la zone d'incertitude ça a
été les france et l'étranger
je la connais parfaitement j'étais
secrétaire d'état le premier ce quota
l'état des français de l'étranger
j'ai commencé à mettre en place et voir
qu'on si elle l'a fait après quand je
suis parti aux sports le vote de la
présidentielle pour les français de
l'étranger lui non seulement le vote
pour la présidentielle et les députés
qui est totalement différent qui a été à
cette époque totalement différent entre
un vote classique
papier pour le président et un vote avec
quatre systèmes différents
le vote électronique la procuration le
vote classique et ensuite le vot bon peu
importe donc je connais parfaitement la
difficulté on parle de quoi on parle de
personnes qui sont 70% des votants sont
un support à sont les grandes villes
dans lesquelles on peut mettre des
bureaux de vote sans aucun problème
voilà non pas de 30 % de personnes qui
sont à l'écart très à l'écart des
conflits quelquefois compliqué
dangereuse mais c'est pas un problème
mais sur ce sujet est-ce que l'ambiance
était tendue avec une passe d'armes
entre nicolas sarkozy alain juppé pas de
passion entre les deux pour moi non
voilà pour moi non le problème n'en
était pas un le problème a été mis en
exergue
parce qu'au départ on ne parlait que du
vote papier tout le monde était rongé
là-dessus personnes avaient probablement
et d'un seul coup le vote électronique
on ne sait comment s'est immiscé dans
cette affaire-là donc il a fallu le
régler ça on va en reparler va revenir
plus longuement sur cette primaire de
rater votre soutien à nicolas sarkozy à
la fin de cette émission dans l'album du
scan mais on va continuer à dérouler
l'actualité parlementaire puisque mardi
n'est rien même connerie et est
auditionné devant les sénateurs
devant la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat le projet de loi elle
conneries qui arrivera au sénat le 13
juin et la ministre du travail se dit
déterminée j'aborde le débat au sénat
dans un état d'esprit fait de
détermination et de gravité aussi une
détermination à parler enfin du contenu
du texte
en s'affranchissant ainsi possible de
certaines postures aussi contenu
qu'artificielle et une gravité apporter
un texte qui je crois est juste et
nécessaire pour notre pays
david douillet à la majorité sénatoriale
qui souhaitent revenir au texte initial
est ce que vous comptez sur le sénat
pour qui le gouvernement n'a pas du tout
sûr je me mets à genoux devant eux
haut lieu parisien qu'il le fasse bien
sûr qu'ils nous renvoient un texte à
nouveau remplie rempli de bonnes chances
de bonnes choses qui vont nous faire
dégager de l'immobilisme qui existe dans
ce pays pour entreprendre pour créer la
richesse mejia mal comment ils passent
au 10
on se rendit sion elle monte au créneau
alors oui je gêne aussi oui c'est
courageux mais à chemin de croix avec
une croix que qu'on lui a mis sur les
épaules que françois hollande lui a mis
sur les épaules est élu il a lui fait
supporter cette croix qui est énorme
parce que parce qu'il en est le
responsable
il a il a manipulé en corse de ceux qui
ont voté pour lui tous ceux qui ont cru
en lui ceux qui sont dans l'hémicycle là
c'est c'est du jamais vu pour un
gouvernement à deux personnes deux
députés près il y avait une motion de
rejet qui était votée qui était présenté
et 1 et par la gauche c'est du jamais vu
mais il ya eu encore une deuxième
lecture les choses peuvent
éventuellement si les choses vont
tellement se passer et puis on voit
qu'on est l'armé absolue qu'est le 49-3
qui va nous tomber dessus alors vous
pensez qu'elle s'est fait déjà que de
toute façon le gouvernement l'utilisera
moral franchement je pense je pense
on va voir le travail des députés on va
de quelle manière ils vont m'aimer pas
quand la qualité leurs travaux mais de
quelle manière cela ils sont montés mais
je pense qu'on y arrivera en attendant
la mobilisation se poursuit dans la rue
128 personnes ont encore manifesté hier
des manifestations sont annoncées
notamment le cas le soir font sur les 60
présidents sont 10 millions alors un
déjà c'est un premier pas c'est une
minorité qui fédère vous minimisez la
continent je suis pas mais je comprends
les gens qui sont déçus je comprends
franchement jeu on n'a pas les mêmes
idées mais je me mets à leur place je me
suis fait avoir et et c'est cet essai
cette revendication là on entend en
réalité mais sur le fond du texte et le
fond de cette loi on en a besoin mais en
urgence il faut il faudra aller bien
plus loin que ce que même dans la
première version de la loi est claire il
faut aller bien plus loin que ce qui est
proposé
mais c'est surtout que ces
manifestations se déroulent dans un
climat tendu avec parfois de la violence
est ce que vous craignez une radicale
basque est le gouvernement excusez moi
mais les policiers depuis depuis la 5ème
république ont dû défiler si je ne me
trompe pas quatre fois c'est la
troisième fois on va venir maintenant
c'est deux fois sous gouvernement
hollande ou en octobre 2015 pour
conséquence contesté madame taubira et
là encore cette fois enregistré deux
fois sous gouvernement hollande on parle
de la sec on est allés chez le cinquième
république
vous rendez compte on va venir un sur
cette médiatisation des policiers
puisque mercredi le descendait dans la
rue les policiers qui dénoncent un
manque de reconnaissance disent leur
ras-le-bol de la haine et de la violence
à leur encontre
ils sont donc descendus mercredi dans la
rue mais à paris des casseurs ont
incendié un véhicule de police blessant
ses deux occupants
rim benameur une scène d'une violence
sans précédent
des casseurs ont essayé de mettre le feu
à une voiture de police alors que deux
fonctionnaires sont à l'intérieur
peu après quatre personnes sont
interpellées
une enquête est ouverte pour tentative
d'homicide volontaire
réaction immédiate de manuel valls il
promet d'autres interpellations et des
sanctions implacable il faut agir
interpellé et faire en sorte que la
justice sur la base de preuves qui soit
le plus net possible puisse condamner
avec la plus grande fermeté et ces
nouvelles violences interviennent en
plein débat sur la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est indigné face à ces
brutalités j'aurais énormément de
difficultés à considérer qu'il ya
derrière ces hordes sauvages
quelque chose qui ressemble à de
l'humanité ou a fortiori un début idéal
depuis des semaines à chaque
manifestation les affrontements entre
casseurs et forces de l'ordre se répète
inadmissible pour la droite qui
dénoncent le laxisme du gouvernement
david douillet dans une fonction vous
êtes chargé de veiller à l'image de la
france à l'étranger
cette voiture brûlée a fait le tour
cette info
l'immobilisme du gouvernement tout ça
pour faire plaisir à quelques jeunes
gauchistes et et tout ça dans des
attitudes déjà électoraliste de la part
du candidat hollande info quand même
bien de souligner cette affaire là on ne
sécurise pas comme il le faudrait
les manifestations le résultat une
voiture brûlée des images qui ont fait
le tour du monde
je vous le dis c'est plusieurs milliards
se sont envolés dans cette voiture
plusieurs milliards de retombées
économiques elle a fait le tour du monde
cette image là on a eu l'année dernière
les les attentats terroristes
donc c'est catastrophique siens
catastrophiques pour l'économie
française parce que qu'est-ce que les
caisses qu'à l'étranger se dit je vous
rappelle que rien que sur l'île de
france les retombées économiques du
touriste et 21 milliards 30 % moins à
cause des attentats
cette année qu'est ce que cette image va
redonner encore que là c'est nous mêmes
parce que on est on est on se met dans
l'incapacité on ne veut pas sécurisé on
met pas les moyens pour sécuriser une
manifestation c'est à dire qu'on laisse
faire vous dites qu à une défaillance
grave du système de maintien de l'ordre
et des dames de forme l'autorité de
l'état
parce que à la tête de l'état que ce
soit le ministre de l'intérieur comme le
président l'a public
on a donné des consignes laxistes
regardez dans tous les autres
gouvernements on n'a jamais assisté à
des choses comme ça c'est une première
pourquoi posez vous la question mais sur
le fond du problème un au delà des
violences les policiers manifestent
aussi contre une surcharge de travail
contre une baisse des effectifs est ce
que la droite n'appelle responsabilités
sur ce sujet une responsabilité de
qu'est l'or parce que nous avons voulu
des effets de seuil et de lettres les
budgets vous savez c on a voulu remettre
les policiers dans la rue
le message a été complètement détourné
marketé par une gauche qui est arrivé au
pouvoir envers vous avez réduit les
effectifs pas du tout en réalité on a
voulu réorganiser le système policier
pour que des gens qui ne font que de
l'administratif que de l'administration
reviennent à leur métier initial c'est
ce qui était en alors 7 a été stoppée
par la gauche ajoie sont tout de suite
les casseurs
comment arrêter les casseurs ce que vous
avez une mesure choc vous pas arrêter
ils sont identifiés regardez dans la
majorité d'entre eux en garde tous ceux
qui ont qui ont commis ces méfaits
contre cette voiture était connu des
services avaient déjà été condamnés pour
la plupart d'entre eux étaient interdits
de participer à des manifestations
mais quand on fait une indication tout
ça est encadrée on peut contrôler d
identité véritable
mais bien sûr je suis pas ministre de
l'intérieur mais si je les paie il ya
une manifestation qui dit qui démarre on
a des policiers en civil qui sont
capables à l'oeil de voir au niveau
niveau vestimentaire pour certains parce
qu'on ne sait il ya des capuches pour
ceux masqués et c'est de dire vos
papiers etc de contrôler les gens qui
ont déjà été condamnés n'ont pas le
droit de participer à une manifestation
c'est du laxisme à l'état pur voilà je
vous le dis aux bahamas et au jeudi
david douillet jeudi une pétition sur la
rémunération des patrons dans libération
quarante personnalités responsables
politiques syndicaux ou intellectuels
ont lancé un appel pour demander au
gouvernement de légiférer afin de
limiter le salaire des patrons
elsa monde un gavage le patron du parti
socialiste jean christophe cambadélis
l'économiste thomas piketty la députée
écologiste cécile duflot ou encore le
leader de la cgt philippe martinez tous
ont signé un appel dans le quotidien
libération pour demander au gouvernement
de légiférer pour qu'un patron ne
perçoivent pas plus de 100 smic
depuis quelques semaines les révélations
sur les salaires des grands patrons font
scandale
paul hermelin chez capgemini et sa
rémunération à 4,8 millions d'euros ou
encore celle de carlos ghosn le patron
de renault 7,2 millions d'euros dans ce
cas elle a été décidé contre l'avis de
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires le
premier ministre propose que ce ne soit
plus possible donc il faut donner aux
actionnaires davantage du pouvoir pour
que ceux qui s'augmente ces
rémunérations puis devant leurs
actionnaires
revenir sur ses décisions si c'est
nécessaire le gouvernement est déjà
plafonné la rémunération des dirigeants
d'entreprises dont l'état détient la
majorité du capital pour les entreprises
privées
un code de bonne conduite a été édité
par le patronat mais il apparaît
aujourd'hui insuffisant des amendements
vont donc être déposé dans le cadre de
la loi sapin 2 mais une voix dissonante
s'est déjà fait entendre la personne du
ministre de l'économie je pense que
c'est un mauvais sujet pour la loi je ne
pense pas que le législateur dans un
seul pays puisse dans un monde ouvert
considérer qu'il y à un plafond de
rémunération je pense que ça reste la
décision de l'entreprise le même
emmanuel mac
qui avait menacé de légiférer il y a
deux semaines lors des questions au
gouvernement
emmanuel macron ne crois pas qu'on
puisse encadrer les avants c'est ce que
vous avez dit dans votre reportage
il a dit la verse 15 jours avant qu'on y
met donc en vous maintenant voilà c'est
un produit marketing
voilà sur le fond est ce que vous
soutenez vous cet appel une fois
légiférer non non c'est 40 signataires
tous de gauche évidemment sont enfin
j'aimerais qu'il se réveille et qu'ils
s'aperçoivent dans quel monde ils vivent
voilà si nous vivions dans un monde
globalisé communiste voilà détenus pas
un parti qui régit tout le monde entier
ils peuvent le faire
on peut le faire c'est pas le cas c'est
comme ça donc qu'est ce qui se passe
tout seul tout mot grand patron
que ce soit ceux qui créent leur
entreprise ou ceux qui les gèrent après
ecsta tous ceux qui ont du talent on
partir on va plus les avoir les bons et
les bourgs est logique de là mais bon on
a bien su fusionner les marchés mais
messieurs c'est comme c'est comme une
équipe de foot
les meilleurs joueurs vont être pris
ailleurs s'il vous plaît si vous
plafonner leurs salaires il ya voilà ils
vont partir ils vont être ils vont être
pris par deux entreprises aux états-unis
en australie où vous voulez et ils ne
seront plus chez nous il ne développe en
développant plus de de la même manière
avec toutes les qualités qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui pour développer nos
entreprises françaises ils ne seront
plus là je veux dire quoi en disant ça
que c'est absurde de de partir se sait
sur ces contrées là d'ailleurs les
conseils d'administration ou les
actionnaires les actionnaires comme ça
pour voir
oui j'ai lancé au pouvoir n'est pas
forcément contre 2 n'est pas
contraignant est-ce qu'il faut rendre sa
décision à ce que j'ai en ce que je sais
que je pense sur ces sujets là c'est
vrai que quelquefois il y a de la
justice il y à une injustice terrible
qui est scandaleuse c'est lorsqu'un
grand patron s'en va dans notre truc
d'une entreprise avec un parachute
puisque doré et lorsqu'il a mis avant
reprise en déficit ou dans une situation
si catastrophique ça c'est scandaleux
mais lorsqu'un patron ce qu'est le cas
de ceux dont on a parlé à capgemini
seconde où les autres réussissent
remplissent les
carnet de commandes font progresser
l'entreprise développe l'emploi et créer
de la richesse
mais ça me dérange pas qu'ils soient
bien payés ces gens là voilà par contre
une petite répétition un peu plus un peu
plus valorisante pour toute l'entreprise
en général aussi doit aller de pair mais
par contre un patron qui échoue doit
être sanctionné et ne plus nous pas être
dansé dansé niveau de rémunération c'est
hors de question
c'est injuste la méritocratie doit être
appliquée à plein sur ce sujet alors on
va revenir à l'assemblée vous et y étiez
les députés donc vous ont voté après les
sénateurs la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence pour permettre des mesures
exceptionnelles notamment pendant l'euro
de foot qui commence très bientôt l'état
d'urgence est prolongée de deux mois
françois goulard pour 46 contre 20 donc
l'article unique est adoptée la
troisième prorogation de l'état
d'urgence est officiellement voté elle
instaure deux mois supplémentaires de
mesures exceptionnelles en termes de
lutte contre le terrorisme
le ministre de l'intérieur a évoqué la
gravité de la menace et l'imminence de
l'euro de football pour convaincre les
parlementaires et ne nous est pas permis
de nous croire à l'abri ni de considérer
que le péril imminent qui a justifié en
novembre dernier la proclamation de
l'état d'urgence a disparu j'ajoute que
dans les mois qui viennent les enjeux de
sécurité seront particulièrement
importants pour des raisons qui tiennent
à l'organisation de cette grande
manifestation qu'est l'euro 2016 et
d'autres manifestations estivales
la majorité des députés socialistes à
voter pour la provocation avec dans le
texte une modification le retrait des
perquisitions administrative durant les
premières semaines qui ont suivi le 13
novembre
les perquisitions administratives ont
été nombreuses elles ont permis de
chercher et de trouver les
renseignements nécessaires pour
désorganiser les réseaux terroristes
désormais elle ne bénéficie plus ni de
l'effet de surprise ni de l'utilité
spécifiques qui les justifiait au cours
des six derniers mois
une décision à laquelle s'est opposé le
groupe l'est républicain
qui souhaite également que le
gouvernement utilise avec plus de force
les outils de l'état d'urgence oui nous
vous appelons monsieur le ministre à
faire plus d'interdictions de
rassemblement qui troublent l'ordre
public
oui nous vous appelons à faire plus de
perquisitions administratives pouvant
protéger les français quant au député du
front de gauche
il voit dans ce nouveau vote une dérive
sécuritaire de l'exécutif
est ce que cette prolongation de l'état
d'urgence était nécessaire de vraiment
pour obligatoire mais est-ce qu est-ce
qui sera va être efficace surtout aussi
si c'est aussi efficace que pendant les
manifestations
on a on a de quoi se préoccuper voilà et
on a une grosse préoccupation à voir si
on veut parler des fans zone par exemple
deux françaises sous la tour eiffel sous
la tour eiffel
quand on regarde très précisément les
les objectifs que s'est mit s'est imposé
des ch pour aller toucher notre notre
monde qui est un monde de liberté etc
la tour eiffel figure en première liste
et à les interdire phison à refaire vous
rendez compte c'est servir sur un
plateau une occasion de faire un
massacre massif alors de personnes que
le gouvernement a évolué lors de ne pas
interdire ces familles dès le départ est
sûr qu'il a tort et et peut-il encore le
faire une folie sans créer un
gouvernement peut tout faire sans
crainte si vous ne pouvez pas faire dans
un gouvernement n'a pas lieu d'être dans
un gouvernement sait qu'il doit le faire
peur c'est urgent de le faire on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas laisser ça vient
c'est trop c'est trop bon tour eiffel
des centaines de milliers de personnes
tous les jours
hollande doit interdire les fans zone en
tout cas celles qui sont aussi
symbolique que celle là mais ça veut
dire quelque part c'est la mort et pas
celle dans les autres villes hôtes de
france toutes celles qui sont qui
peuvent être compliquées ou symboliques
ou voit la cccc vraiment
prêté le bâton pour cela battre moi je
trouve ça extrêmement inconscient que de
2,2 laisser faire c'est ce gouvernement
en se disant oui on voit moins de mots
nos fans zone sous l'arc de triomphe dit
que la sécurité de ses fans zone est
assurée vous n'y croyez pas ah ben
excusez moi est ce que la voiture là
pendant la manif ils amènent les
manifestations des policiers est ce que
la sécurité était là est-ce que la
sécurité est là depuis des semaines où
on voit des des manifestations avec des
casseurs à l'intérieur qui font ce
qu'ils veulent comme ils veulent est ce
que la sécurité est là on est ouverts
tournés en état d'urgence
le gouvernement n'est pas capable ou ne
veut pas appliquer les règles strictes
de l'état d'urgence est donc vraiment de
sécuriser tout mouvement de
manifestations ou des rassemblements
tels que pourraient être les fans zone
de l'euro donc oui bien sûr qu'il ya
préoccupations on a des exemples clients
qui ont lieu cette semaine
faut être idiot de ne pas comprendre ça
david douillet après l'euro la france
est candidate pour accueillir les jeux
olympiques de 2024 est-ce que selon vous
la menace terroriste qui pèse sur le
pays va empêcher paris d'être désignée
ville hôte
non la menace terroriste en réalité on
le voit de par les attentats qui sont
faits dans le monde entier elle existe
elle est là partout on a
particulièrement ciblé ce qu'on a fait
en feront absolument ce qu'on a fait en
france
en revanche c'est de nous doter de tous
les outils pour compliquer la vie à ces
mêmes terroristes
en réalité ça veut dire quoi c'est comme
si vous avez vu vous avez votre maison
avec une vote porte d'entrée et vous
n'aviez qu'un verrou avant donc
évidemment le voleur mais peu de temps
pour rentrer chez vous là on en a mis 21
ans il met beaucoup de temps ça qu'on ne
parlait dispositions qu'on a prise en
vain on complique grandement la
possibilité de mettre en place des
attentats dans notre pays mais si ils
veulent vraiment le faire ils peuvent le
faire n'importe où d'ailleurs
donc c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
alors je veux pas jeter de l'huile sur
le feu ou quelle jusqu'à une psychose
mais c'est la vérité est la preuve
puisque bizarrement les derniers
attentats ont eu lieu en belgique
juste à côté de chez nous dans un
endroit où
message compris les lois n'avait pas
encore évolué comme ici alors à
poursuivre le film de la semaine puisque
l'assemblée nationale a discuté d'un
projet de loi qui vise à simplifier et
moderniser la justice
les députés ont notamment supprimer les
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs un
dispositif créé par nicolas sarkozy en
2011 pour juger les mineurs récidivistes
de plus de 16 ans david douillet ces
tribunaux ne traiter que 1% des
contentieux c'est un constat
c'est un constat d'échec c'était
nécessaire de les réformer quand on a un
dispositif au départ qui qui part sur un
un bond qui est un bon principe les
tribunaux gouvernants mon principe au
départ des multirécidivistes on le
reconnaît
moi j'habite à côté des mureaux voilà je
connais bien la question dans les
yvelines
il faut se poser les questions se
remettre en question mais de là à tous
supprimés et a touché non vous êtes
contre moi je sais je suis pour une une
autre appréciation pour remettre des
enfants dans le chemin de la vie parce
que c'est ça dont il s'agit
or et comment comment comment en temps
il ya des choses formidables
d'ailleurs qui auraient pu être mises en
place en leur donnant le choix ou la
possibilité de commuer leur première
peine sur d'autres dispositifs notamment
encadrés pourquoi pas et à l'époque
j'avais imaginé ce dispositif mais il ya
très longtemps j'étais encore je venais
finau maka d'athlètes sur le bataillon
de joinville savait qu'entre le service
militaire a été supprimé le batte un
jour il calculé tous les athlètes de
haut niveau s'est retrouvé sans son
ensemble sans objectifs sont l'objet bon
le belge avait il y avait toutes les
installations sportives
oui l'idée leur solution militaire tous
les athlètes de niveau faisait peser
leur service militaire là pour pas
perdre de temps et continuer à être
performants bon on en faisait une école
de la seconde chance à travers le sport
encadrés par des militaires oui où on
propose un enfant et il aurait pu
décider de ne pas le faire mais en tout
cas de commuer sa peine de prison sa
première peine de prison en
apprentissage d'un métier à travers le
sport mais aussi dans un environnement
st et et et ont lors établissements dans
je me couche tôt je me lève tôt je mange
sainement je fais du sport je m'occupe
de mon corps et puis j'apprends des
choses et en le formant un métier du
sport c'est formidable non 6 bon c'est
des initiatives comme ça on a besoin
je suis trop long c'est ça un peu un peu
bon je suis pas sûr on va terminer avec
l'actualité d'hier puisque depuis hier
david douillet l'assemblée nationale
compte un groupe ii - les écologistes
réformiste emmenée par françois de rugy
ont décidé de rallier le groupe
socialiste entraînant de facto la
disparition du groupe écologiste qui ne
comptent plus assez de membres pour
exister à strip de vilaine tout avait
pourtant si bien commencé
juin 2012 pour la première fois de leur
histoire les écologistes parviennent à
former un groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale
grâce à un accord avec le parti
socialiste la majorité fonctionne deux
ministres écolo sont même au
gouvernement
mais deux ans plus tard cécile duflot
n'accepte pas la nomination de manuel
valls à matignon elle claque la porte du
gouvernement et fait son grand retour à
l'assemblée nationale
travailler deux tendances cohabitent
alors au sein d'un même groupe
parlementaire ce qui reste fidèle à la
ligne gouvernementale et ceux qui se
placent dans l'opposition les divisions
devienne intenable
ils ont droit de dire ce qu'ils veulent
par contre nous on n'a pas être
comptable des expressions de cécile
duflot de noël mamère on peut importe
octobre 2015 de nombreux cadres
historiques d'europe écologie les verts
quittent le parti pour créer leur propre
mouvement légitime à la ligne de
françois hollande proposons une écologie
positive
il est possible de propositions
cousine écologique d'actes ou de réalité
le groupe est au bord de l'implosion
pour le sauver françois de rugy cède sa
place à cécile duflot le groupe assume
alors deux lignes politiques
il peut y avoir des nuances sur la
manière d'exprimer cette réponse y
compris sur les questions tactiques mais
ça c'est pas nouveau et ça ne va pas
changer deux présidentes de réunion de
groupe
deux positions sur les grands textes de
loi
malgré les divisions le groupe survie
par intérêt audi reste parce que il y en
existe pas l'assemblée nationale si on
appartient pas
un groupe pour la rep ou ne serait ce
que pour accomplir du travail
parlementaire
on survit dans ce dans ce groupe divisé
qui ne sert qu'à une chose à ne
permettre de travailler février 2016
françois hollande acte la rupture en
nommant trois écologistes de premier
choix au gouvernement
barbara pompili coprésidente du groupe à
l'assemblée jean vincent placé président
de l'ue des oeufs et la propre
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts
emmanuelle cosse des nominations
stratégiques qui aggrave encore un peu
plus la fracture entre les deux lignes
ces dernières semaines la sphère
beaupain achève le groupe à l'assemblée
les négociations pour son remplacement
au poste de vice président est mal
tourné la situation politique pleine de
rancoeur personnelle ne pouvait plus
durer
david douillet cette explosion du groupe
ex écologiste est ce que c'est une
illustration de la volonté trans
hollande d'éliminer toute concurrence à
gauche
ouais c'est une belle stratégie - vous
moi je dis chapeau williams avant oui
bah oui là il
il avait démarré on l'a on le sentait
bien on le voyait en son père on le sait
transpirait dès le début du quinquennat
et s'est attaché à tout ça et dès qu'il
a pu en sortir pour les nommer leur
proposer des postes et c'est du show
était passé avant guitare voilà le truc
ce parti a explosé complètement
littéralement on la vit aussi à
l'échelle de l'île de france avec 4
toute façon le socialiste et les
écologistes élus les vinaigres cette
régie n'a pas pu être gérée correctement
pour ses besoins
le jean paul huchon à l'époque a été
prise au piège dans un état terrible et
malmené par le groupe écologiste qui lui
a fait faire dans beaucoup de domaines à
peu près n'importe quoi voilà c'est une
catastrophe terrible dans cette
affaire-là
c'est que pour des raisons politiques
l'écologie la vraie écologie qui est ni
de droite ni de gauche en pâtit en fait
alors c'est l'heure maintenant de parler
de revenir à l'actualité briques de
votre parti tout de suite la loupe du
scan
bonjour bonjour c'est à vous bonjour
david douillet bonjour excusez moi là
d'un problème technique
allez-y ça me permet de poser laquelle
la première question sur nicolas sarkozy
hier soir délai les soutiens les membres
de l'association de soutien à l'action
nicolas sarkozy ont reçu un mail de
votre part david douillet qui commence
ainsi je continue à me battre pour la
france et c'est pour cela que j'ai
choisi de m'engager au côté nicolas
sarkozy rejoignez nous est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il ya une accélération dans
le mouvement qui va vers la candidature
j'espère bien de nicolas sarkozy mais il
faut bien dire frenchy faut regarder on
est belle oui on est on est pressé par
et remet le démarrage de la primaire le
dépôt des contraintes de la candidature
le nombre de parlementaires de signature
les deux missionnaires salle et ambre
début septembre il ya l'été qui au
milieu de tout ça il faut déjà parce que
moi je vais l'appeler à se présenter dès
aujourd'hui ah mais oui dément fin le
plus rapidement possible parce qu'on en
a besoin d'avoir eu trop grande dans
l'arène rapidement mais rapidement avant
l'été j'espère ouais j'espère maintenant
vous lui montrez lui il dit
là je lui ai gagné respectifs à sapouy
et comme je l'avais dit en en 2012 qui
pour qu'il démarre un peu plus tôt à
l'époque je le pense oui il faut pas
reproduire c'est très exactement
d'accord alors s'il n'est pas encore
candidat il nicolas sarkozy ne se prive
pas pour autant de cibler ses
adversaires ses futurs adversaires à la
primaire que dit ti par exemple sur sur
juppé on peut tout dire mais pas qu'il a
du talent qu'est ce qui dit sur fion il
n'a pas d'idées pas d'originalité
est-ce que l' attaque frontale c'est la
bonne stratégie d'abord la joueuse je me
suis toujours étonné de ces mots de ces
phrases qui reviennent comme ça qui
surgissent de nulle part qui sont
peut-être sorti d'un contexte il l'a dit
dans l'avion de dans le retour de
l'avion de new delhi à une journaliste
du point qu'il a acquis la
retranscription
moi je suis toujours méfiante s'est
hissé à faire et bohème été victime de
phrases sorties de contexte soit dans un
livre ou autre chose je suis toujours
méfiant tout ce que je sais c'est ce que
j'ai vécu au sein d'un gouvernement avec
lui et y compris avec alain juppé
lorsque je suis rentré au ministère des
affaires étrangères comme secrétaire
d'état on a là des hommes de grande
qualité
voilà je vous le dis on a cette chance
c'est quand même incroyable tant mieux
des hommes d'état donc voila moi je
considère que mes amis ma tension qui
s'installent autour de nos mauvais que
ça c'est ça c'est des vues c'est un
climat qui n'est pas négatif c'est ça je
veux vous faire comprendre concurrentiel
mais la négative
c'est sain c'est normal c'est de la
concurrence et c'est normal et de cette
concurrence et c'est moi le seul
avantage que je peux j'espère tirer
enfin que pour notre groupe de cette
primaire c'est qui est une émulation des
idées des talents voilà parce qu'ils ont
tous du talent et et si la raison pour
laquelle je suis nicolas sarkozy sait
que ce talent il nous l'a déjà montré
est que ce talent là
la première chose à mon sens ce qui
devrait faire c'est que on en aura
besoin grandement de son poids de son
envergure politique à l'échelle de
l'europe non parce qu'il faut d'abord
régler ce problème de l'europe avant de
s'attacher à nos problèmes nationaux
autre phrase rapportée de nicolas
sarkozy toujours dans le point ce
monsieur trump donc donald trump le
candidat républicain
l'élection américaine est réussie parce
qu'il ne se refuse aucune outrance assez
nicolas 4 sarkozy t-il dit est-ce que ce
ça peut être un modèle nord nicolas
sarkoy non sûr que l'on n'est pas aux
états unis vous verrez et c'est enfin je
pense un signe ne sera pas élu monsieur
trempe que tron va changer complètement
d'attitude il va plus être aussi
provocateur il va rentrer dans le rang
il va flatter les gens qui sont très
conservateur et très frileux et vous
verrez que il arrêtera d'être dans un
populisme et que ce dernier christian
lors d'une récente visite dans le rhône
nicolas sarkozy a indiqué que laurent
wauquiez ferait probablement l'intérim
lorsqu'il sera candidat à la primaire
l'intérim à la présidence du parti
est ce que il est suffisamment
rassembleur pour cela dans une période
où justement le rap le parti aura besoin
de se réunir
c'est la partie moi je remercie nicolas
sarkozy et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je suis d'avoir su refaire un
parti on est reparti de zéro en réalité
après le cataclysme copé fillon il a
reconstruit
il a rassemblé les gens ils à
désendetter un parti il a remis un
projet en route un projet d'opposition
en route
bref il a fait le job ou quoi et c'est
juste formidable laurent wauquiez il
peut qu'il peut continuer ce job là il
il savait qu'en arrivant quand même au
sein du parti a beaucoup en général
chacun a du caractère et rami mais parce
que nous arrivons tant vous savez vision
juste de second rang général c'est quand
les voix sont tracés quand on la pose et
les les lignes de la ligne de chemin de
fer
quand on met le train dessus nicolas
sarkozy a à construire la ligne d un
public 1 et et laurent ne sera que la
locomotive continuera à voguer sans bon
sens c'est noté merci beaucoup merci
merci david douillet d'avoir fait la
semaine avec nous et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition de parlement hebdo